noi siamo 0 c
benvenute e benvenuti alla prima puntata
di feroci un podcast antologico di
undici puntate che a me piace immaginare
come un viaggio atipico eterogeneo
controcorrente che vuole mettere al
centro della propria bussola l'essere
umano ogni puntata questo studio
accoglierà infatti una persona che più
che un ospite sarà uno strumento ciò che
questo podcast cerca sono spunti di
conoscenza di riflessione di analisi e
autoanalisi di stampo archetipo un
viaggio di questo tipo è sicuramente
ambizioso ed è proprio per questo che ho
deciso di condividerlo con due persone
diverse da me ma che sento molto affini
me che per qualche strano motivo hanno
messo il proprio sguardo sul mondo la
propria sensibilità e il proprio tempo
al servizio di questa scommessa ecco
perché per me è un onore presentarvi co
conduttori di feroci michele bravi e
lollo barolo
io ho dovuto fare tutta questa cosa con
loro sotto al tavolo
elegante sai che è un peccato che tutta
la grinta edizione non ci fosse sicura
telecamera sulla faccia di lollo quanto
la vedevi la faccio chiara lunghi
dibattiti
[Musica]
logico è conosce
pronti allora facciamo si parte proprio
un ospite michele vuoi farci tool onore
per forza di resistance ejelo toccati
aspetta michele
chiari ea palese ha fatto parli corsivo
quando voglio ma veramente c'è gente
parla così a non c'è creato amo giuro
non ci credo ma serie
c'è gente che paga allora non è chi ha
poco di ha però è tipo così e che
proponiamo tanti il nostro viaggio parte
dall esteriorità dalla superficie ma non
dalla superficialità se stessimo
cercando il centro della terra in questo
momento ci troveremmo davanti alla bocca
di un vulcano spento qualcosa di
meraviglioso terribile ma che porta con
sé la promessa di un segreto viviamo in
una società che da estremo valore al
mondo in cui decidiamo di apparire ma mi
state
proteste
ma li schivitù ste robe si vede sica
qualcosa qui lo ha scritto pensando a te
e per quello che ho messo un vulcano
spento capitali europee quelle immagini
oniriche che pronuncerà sulla tua in
sicurezza
eppure allo stesso tempo viviamo in una
società che ci filtra ci vede e ci
analizza il milioni di modi diversi
quanto ci rappresenta quello che
indossiamo quanto ci rende unici quanto
c omologa quanto ci protegge quanto ci
rende vulnerabili
si chiama di oggi
abbiamo deciso di avere come ospite
mixer ionio e per introdurlo ecco un
breve hyde anziché allora voglio
imparare a parlare
divertente a mio nome vendola cerioni
professione stylist e direttore creativo
ha uno studio a new york ea milano dove
si diploma all'istituto europeo di
design la sua carriera nasce grazie a un
tweet inviato a jovanotti muove i primi
passi nella moda in mtv poi ex factor
per sony e infine il festival di sanremo
collabora con jovanotti da dieci anni ma
vanta anche altre collaborazioni con
alcuni dei più importanti cantanti
italiani tra cui laura pausini maneschi
achille lauro dark polo gang e orietta
berti con suo marito cerioni ha fondato
google che è in studio
la casa di produzione di video dvd live
editoriali fotografie di moda e video
musicali riconoscere raffaella carrà la
sua musa ispiratrice nella sua vita
privata è sposato con leandro è papà di
due gemelli allora vai faccio vedere
nick vs
voi siete fighissimi ragazzi o
nick nic allora tu non sei venuto qui
essere umili e farmi tale che le persone
successo possono essere curati per terra
è perché in due secondi cifra tutti
girano i [ __ ] allora nick
innanzitutto grazie grazie alla star che
in questo momento sta sfondando l'imene
di questo podcast praticamente sei lì ci
sono prima volta senza prima volta ma
come nasce la passione per la moda io ti
devo dire che odio la moda
ti prego io io
amo troppo noi
no allora non ho una passione per la
moda ti dico la verità ok io sono
cresciuto con una grande passione per le
entrate in mente in generale sono uno di
quei bambini anni 80 che stavano davanti
alla televisione h24
se stesso e quindi sono cresciuto un po
con quelle referenze visive lì per me la
reference visiva massima è stata
raffaella carrà poi stata madonna e
niente quindi per me la la grande
passione stata errata la musica il
teatro il cinema la televisione quindi
la moda mi piaceva mi piace quando è
utile per esprimere qualcosa sapori
esprimere oggi qualcosa di
extraterrestre
grazie nico posso fare anche a te la
stessa domanda
tu invece vogliamo io sto sudando credo
anche dalla no ragazzi cioè è veramente
o il mare nel sotto palla e
ragazze vi precede comunque sempre con
moretti a tutti i ragazzi la mia ansia e
che io ho capito che nick è una persona
di contenuto ecco dall'altra parte omega
re bravi ok noi due ti prego almeno noi
due lollo ci impegniamo a riportare ha
[Applauso]
fatto il gesto giusto perché sennò poi è
l'iperuranio in due secondo set i
modelli spi razionali raffaella carrà
quindi è tale e quale c'è anche il
tatuaggio
e poi cosa è successo
ho fatto una scuola di moda perché mi
sembrava un po l'unica roba che potessi
fare in quanto capra nucleare
spalle perché è tutto bellissimo ma
credo che sia fatta della stessa materia
le del sacco dell'umido questa cosa
e poi niente da lì e succede che mi sono
diplomato in questa bellissima scuola di
moda milanese e nessuno mi voleva io ero
quello troppo diverso non ero nei giri
della milano
cul non ero bello abbastanza per farmi
notare da quelli che dove per cui dovevi
essere bello non ero figo abbastanza
nero quindi nemmeno la possibilità di
fare favori sessuali in cambio di un
lavoro neanche non me l'hanno mai
proposto che mamma quando ci si deve
veramente fare da zero che pare proprio
così e poi è arrivata quella che per me
è stata la grande occasione cioè quella
di andare a lavorare adjani tv succede
poi che diversi anni dopo antivj chiude
o meglio si trasforma in un altra cosa
cioè quindi tutti i programmi chiudo noi
ci ritroviamo da un giorno all altro in
140 senza lavoro una roba in creando
incredibile è stato un po uno shock io
avevo già conosciuto quello che poi
sarebbe diventato il mio socio il mio
marito che si chiama leandro
manuel emede fa il fotografo il regista
e noi avevamo un'idea che era quella di
forma ed era un sogno che volevamo
aprire uno studio creativo anche li ha
mandati a bussare alle porte nessuno ci
cagava finché non siamo andati a los
angeles dove leandro sognava si di fare
un master alla juve si rifaceva questo
questo corso che non faceva un cazzo
quindi fondamentalmente
riservi allora ciò quindi era veramente
e succede che a los angeles un giorno
che eravamo una domenica mi ricordo
ancora in spiaggia scopriamo che
jovanotti sarebbe venuto a fare due
piccoli show vi scriviamo un tweet
privato dicendo siamo qua con due
telecamere si è arrivati facciamo un
piccolo documentario se ti piace loosies
ti fa pagare lo butti logici che avevo
già risposto dopo cinque minuti chiamati
a fare una riunione con lui abbiamo
girato questo video gli è piaciuto e ci
disse l'anno prossimo farò un album voi
farete la regia del dvd live necessarie
di non succederà mai invece è successo
nel tornare in italia ero trovato un
lavoro lavoravo da prada è un certo
punto lorenzo chiama dopo 7 8 mesi
dicendo guarda sto facendo i primi video
mi piacerebbe che tu facessi il
backstage e a un certo punto lorenzo
dice io vorrei un costumista che facessi
vestiti per la mia band perché ho questa
idea di fare la band nei siti tipo un po
super heroes
leandro pacini che ti ricordi lui
lavorare a quello che verteranno sanges
sostavano cazzo si
ok mi sono licenziato da prada e sono
andato in tour con lorenzo ho fatto
questa roba da improvvisato non ho mai
fatto di costumi in bronzo a testa alta
e con tanta cursi chelsea ci sono io
l'ho fatto andata bene e poi da lì
abbiamo cominciato a fare dei video di
lorenzo dove il nell'ultimo video globo
gran finiti i soldi era finito tutto ci
fa o pochissimi soldi ci inventiamo un
video no budget quindi siamo inventati
questo video girato a casa di sua zia
che la video della notte dei desideri
dove l'unica roba che poteva succedere
da che lui cambiasse una marea di
vestiti quindi li ho detto faccio l'in
deve essere la mia il mio biglietto da
visita primi l'acuto e quindi li ho
fatto una ricerca monster in cui video
li fa 19 cambi d'abito pazzeschi
stranissimi folli e dal io poi ho
cominciato a collaborare con lui quindi
lorenzo è stato il primo che la grande
possibilità grazie a quella cosa là io
ho cominciato a lavorare con lorenzo
quindi poi ho avuto un po di attenzione
a dote è certo se smos rockin abbiamo
aperto il nostro studio che sognavamo di
aprire sugarcane esatto e da lì abbiamo
cominciato cosa impariamo da questa
storia non lo che bisogna puntare sui
cantanti e
comunque di nuovo avrei detto tipo
cavalca l'ict un cavalca il momento
perché si trovavano in quel momento per
caso comunque a los angeles per caso e
jovanotti quindi capito cavalca l'onda
ma c'è cavalca l'onda in realtà
sminuente perché se uno cioè sicuramente
un'occasione però poi le occasioni non
le tieni se non hai un talento una cosa
da dire è a michele tu cosa che impara
capito invece io nulla niente
qual è il tuo modo di riuscire a
adattarti a persone che poi sono molto
diverse tra di loro quindi senza essere
prevaricante con quello che magari il
tuo gusto e ma allo stesso tempo per
vedere che ci hai messo la mano allora
guarda io penso sempre che il mio lavoro
sia quello di portare quello che è un
artista dentro su un livello che lui non
riuscirebbe a fare se ha un idea se ha
un identità quella roba raciti di andare
dentro tipo treno perché
oggi funzionano le cose nette di un
certo tipo precise non mi chiamo un
tempo dove lo se fu mattino il lazio per
chi non sa perché chi deve essere sei ok
io odio le cose 6 io odio vedere le cose
però deve deve piacere a tutti non
piacerà a tutti non piaceva tutto gesù
cristo figurati oddio giochiamo
adesso andiamo ok ho avuto anche la
fortuna devo dire benedizione richiamo
più benedizioni perché poi niente sia
casuale di lavorare poi con della gente
che mi ha permesso di fare tanto con
loro chi le lauro che un progetto che
sento particolarmente vicino vuoi
maneschi fin quando l'ho seguito lo
seguiti fino allo scorso dicembre quindi
tu li ha mandati con i bustini a sanremo
avevo potuto un percorso che abbiamo
studiato insieme e quella serata che
dici tu dei corsetti era la mia
preferita in assoluto perché era un
contributo a quello che faceva gauthier
no a tirare fuori l'intimo però in una
maniera
elegantissima secondo me identificava un
po quello che a me piace di damiano un
equilibrio perfetto tra forza e
fragilità tra essere vulnerabile e
essere feroce quando io né mi hanno
chiamato questa terra dico una cosa che
non metto mai a nessuno io ho cominciato
a forma di ricerca estetica e
casualmente in quel periodo grazie a una
scrittrice che si chiama eleonora caruso
che io amo molto che fa un podcast fuori
di testa su slovan galleon e sui fiumi
toyloy
anghelion ma parli della neve certo no
allora devi fare una cosa qui lo dico
davanti a tutti una sera di venire a
milano intimità cena con loro perché vai
fuori di melone
ma io faccio io
cioè che ripetono suo marito che fanno
il podcast acqui matrimonio cui mi sono
fatto invitare
la marcia nuziale era la sigla fatta col
vivono su penso e come questa cosa si
collega perché perché lei poi insieme ad
un'altra ragazza che anche lei adatta e
manga fanno un podcast si chiama ogni
world sul fumetto yaoi che sono quei
fumetti erotici e di stampo poi
omosessuale esatto a un certo punto lei
in questo podcast parla di un fumetto
che si chiama il problema del vento
degli alberi è un'opera molto complessa
e un'opera molto pesante molto bella ma
molto disturbante è una storia
ambientata all'inizio del secolo in un
college francese dove questo principe e
mezzo francese mezzo gitano va in questa
scuola supera esclusiva e lo mettono in
quanto ultimo arrivato nella stanza di
questo gilbert gilbert e l'anima deviata
della scuola il bambino più bello del
mondo bambino ma il ragazzino un
ragazzino più bello del mondo ma che
vive questa bellezza come un punto di
forza una grande condanna perché è così
bello che nessuno può resistere gli
gilber e dannato cibele maledetto quindi
tutta l'immagine di gilbert per me è
stato la referenza visiva principale di
tutta la prima parte del lavoro fatto
coi maneschi dove damiano ha delle
camicie con delle rouge a questo
pantaloni di velluto molto ampio è
esattamente i lupi gilbert e da lì o poi
strutturato il pensiero che dovesse
essere una bellezza
disturbante la sua è la loro quindi
sull'elemento del disturbo
sull'attrazione e la respingente ho
costruito tutta l'immagine di quella
cosa la loro non lo sanno ovviamente
però è stato il tuo il grande inviato io
voglio dire settecento era una cosa che
ci sta ascoltando questo momento
tranquilli ragazzi se voi come me e
ragazze andate da zara e applicatele
prima maglietta bianca non siete da meno
a no ma non chiedeteci un pensiero
dietro un pensiero ok ti ringrazio però
ci si può aversi bene anche con capi non
troppo di marca che consiglio vogliamo
dare le persone che magari vogliono
vestire in maniera si no ricercato che
li rappresenti ma senza cadere capito
nel
magari maglietta bianca e jeans tipo di
vestire anche veramente quella roba
trovata nell'immondizia però 6 come sei
cool c'è madonna negli anni 80 a new
york squattrinata usava della roba
trovata al salvation army
un'incona mondiale di stile cioè non ci
devi far dire agli altri cosa ti devi
mettere per essere figo tu devi
esprimere quello che hai dentro secondo
è una roba l'ace io vedo michele mi sta
parlando da una roba vestito così tu
un'altra tu un altro ancora per me
quella aspetta ti sei appena messo in un
innocente ha ottenuto cosa guarda se poi
mi metto in posa
per raccontarti meglio cosa voglio
raccontare presidente
allora anzitutto lui gioca molto con
questo mix di generi no mi piace che lui
sia sempre non fluido così però ci vedo
la voglia anche di un po di provocarti
perché l'occhiale appunta un po da
cattivissima però la giacca con l'ex
pallone che è un segno dai tempi di
maria antonietta di potere di autorità
che è stato ripreso negli anni ottanta
apposta
però allo stesso tempo sei anche un po
easy perché c'è la maglietta dicessi via
s quindi se comunque 6 c'è una roba
scazzo sotto anche un'arma molto carica
sopra quindi c'è una dualità forte no mi
sento un po sirio vi ricordate
quello che visivamente fa lui lo fa con
grande coraggio a me piace questa roba
che tu hai coraggio sempre anche a
sanremo sia andato con un racconto no e
per me quella cosa lì è vincente perché
non si è passato inosservato e oggi è
quella la chiave cioè tu hai raccontato
una roba anche a chi non era appunto
presenti in sala contare che sono loro
che vanno colpiti lo sai cosa io quella
cosa lì adesso tu lo racconta vi
all'inizio
di come si percepisce la moda noi
all'inizio per me la moda era un
accessorio invadente per la musica il
grande sblocco l'ho avuto quando
iniziato a conoscere dei designer anche
emergenti che proprio mi hanno
raccontato la moda come un processo
creativo che per me la moda era lontana
dalla creatività in maniera
completamente ignorante era miseramente
un pregiudizio il mio nel momento in cui
ho iniziato a capire che dietro un abito
c'è un momento di creatività che tu stai
indossando dal caveau anche quello che
trovi al negozio vintage però un'opera
d'arte che ti metti addosso
allora lì ha iniziato a dire cavolo il
mio corpo può essere uno strumento per
descrivere la musica a 360 gradi con un
momento di spettacolo dove la musica un
pezzettino di spettacolo e tutto il
resto viene fatto da altri creativi e
quindi è lì che a me piace il gioco di
osare e così via ed è per quello che ti
dico mi piaceva molto il modo in cui tu
parlavi all'inizio di moda cosa cazzo
tiri di stato dice
sorridevo nel senso che perde il
servizio a salerno per uno stronzo io
stavo guardando le tutti noi stavamo
sorridendo come per dire ammazza e di
che c'è che bel concerto quella cosa
capiti
marina la rosa del gf1 percorso mi
guarda allora mette invece il nostro
lollo cosa ci racconta oggi allora vedo
una grande voglia di staccarsi noda da
quello che uno può pensare che uno come
te possa mettere perché sei molto safe
no nella parte sopra non sei uno che va
in giro col cappello fluo però sottoposi
e questo è figo perché vuol dire che
introdotte anche dentro itc una dualità
grohl santander è mai infatti poi su
quali mutande
che sta scomparendo
dentro recchia la sfera sta guardando no
comunque io io penso di vestirmi di
merda ma giuro vorrei vorrei aprire
questo discorso a brown perché io sono
vittima dei social e di come tutti si
vestono quindi mi piace rientrare in una
tipologia di
vestiti di comunque stile
però vorrei anche usare però non uso mai
mai mai mai mai mai ma vorresti farlo
vorrei però non so come fare perché bo
mala romana casa cioè
penso se oso viene fuori una cagata però
alla fine cagata per chi ma non ho molta
ma che te ne frega basta la gente ma a
giudizio degli altri ma chi se ne frega
io quando avevo la tua età
aironi ai perché scusami 22
beh
si
aspetta gli ero già stanco male
consegnato tutela
però si riporta male quindi insomma
giriamo su questo allora andiamo avanti
non ho detto quello che penso di te
maglietta bianca sai che fosse
educazione la tua che dovessi sorvolare
per assistere anche lasciare così
sospesa no no no voglio sapere cosa
pensano che cercano un cazzo edi rama
avevi anche la giacchetta tra cui erano
ma modaiolo si vede e si fece la
maglietta giusta quello scollo giusto
c'è anche l'orecchino giusto sia
modaiolo si vede si vede che sei uno che
civili vabbè ma è giusto sia un ri
spettacolo devi essere un po un povero
detto che calcola che stasera mi
toccherà al pensando a questo mandato in
mila clip ripresa da più angolazioni e
detto da te però modaiolo è vissuto come
un'offesa blu kids dap
quindi non mai ha detto rita gare sai
cosa ti dico vado avanti
un'altra domanda mai da genti che sono
adesso c'è la questione al nook parma
cromia note prego ecco volevo chiederti
testa ma devo devo seguire il mio winter
dell
inverno per me una gran cazzata c'è
posto dire mai tutte le
nazim armor out un gene inverni note pre
calzata c'è sicuramente qualcosa che ti
starà meglio di qualcosa altro però
ragazzi anche nella vita incontrare
persone che ti sta ti fanno star meglio
di altre sempre deve incontra persone
nel senso anche nelle relazioni e così
se stai con una persona non è che con
quella esattamente perfetta per te
perché solo con quella dovresti stare tu
devi stare uno sbagliato per te perché
ti fa crescere
aspetta stata è arrivata così professore
di un attimo processarle e alla sa che
cosa ti dico ho scelto veramente i due
compagni per fare questo podcast
migliori che ho conosciuto a scendere
come miss e banale posso dire guarda
veramente ci può essere un rischio a
lavorare con alcuni artisti che poi
quella diventa l'unica tua identità ti
faccio un esempio
91 dei lavori più grandi per la nostra
generazione è stato achille lauro nome
quanto può essere un limite che poi
diventa allora di cerioni fa solo quello
stile lì ma sì
lo è poi boh sticazzi nel senso che
io non è che devo essere democristiano
in quello che faccio cioè io mi piace se
resteremo sto seguendo adesso una roba
che se loro vorranno continuare con me a
merano bucket rai non so perché premia 3
un sacco perché molto lontano il mio
mondo di riferimento ma c'è qualcosa
dentro che mi attrae con il volo cioè
secondo me lì dentro c'è una roba pop
potentissima che non ha espresso tutto
il potenziale che può esprimere qui da
noi forse lo ha espresso all'estero se
tu sei un artista che fa 150 soldati nel
mondo nonché assurda come cosa vuoi che
non siete negli stati uniti vuol dire
che c'è qualcosa che la gente percepisce
ditte di non detto c'è una roba che
arriva la gente e potente parla tu hai
appena e realtà sfoderato una domanda
secondo con chi ti piacerebbe lavorare
in italia allora io ho fatto una corte
ma tipo che neanche mio marito fatto a
bianco ma una corte spietata
[Musica]
esatto adesso te la racconto in breve un
anno fa circa anche di più
scopro su spotify con le varie playlist
la canzone ladro di fiori che mi è
piaciuto un sacco è stato bellissimo e
cominciò subito a capire chi gestiva
blanco scrivere e scopro che lo gestiva
stefano clessi che un manager tra
l'altro manager di fede ho cominciato a
scrivergli tipo tartassando lo voglio
lavorare con blanco ti prego mi piace
anche se adesso supera emergente per
potremmo fare delle cose per lui non ha
fatto praticamente niente
quindi ho avuto anche l'occhio di
captarli prima che si boh mi piaceva poi
mica secondo non mi piace vado dritto ho
fatto sempre così nella vita come
solitamente quando invece vi piacciono
vado dritto
sì sì ma
dopo l'attrice che poteva succedere
sentire il brivido di insistito che è
calato ragazzi io io capisco e da una
parte sommari antonietta dall'altra
parte però dobbiamo andare avanti ma mi
vidi così
per me tu sei sempre pazzesco top è
l'unico modo che io per cercare capito
di valicare questa montagna infinita
emettere di picchettini dentro ma che in
realtà non servono per farti del male ma
servono per riuscire ad arrivare alla
retta che è quello che dicono sempre
quelli che ti dicono che lo mettono
dentro poi no no e poi tutti quanti
afasia
versatile va bene ok a una battuta
finché una sera ad un evento l'unico
evento che sono andato della moda penso
in anni perché oggi gli eventi incontro
fabio novembre il designer che conosco
da tanti anni perché è molto amico di
lorenzo e mi dice dai perché non minacci
adami domani sera a cena con un po di
gente io no guarda non la baby sitter
dei bambini e dai laici blanco ci sono
ci sono e devo sedermi vicino quindi mi
sono fatto invitare mi sono fatto sedere
vicino attaccato un bottone atomico
bianco che poterà basito e meno ma mai
più chiamato
[Musica]
io non discuto per eviterete
pordenone braccio detto
ma scusa domanda ma tu quella che non
hai mai lavorato lavorato no ci ho
provato all'epoca che uscì reeplay il
disco o anche lì o tartassato max
moroldo di email che produceva luigi
disco e moroldo un certo punto sfinito
dalle mie mail ma detto senti la cara
non vuole fare niente non vuole fare un
video non vuole fare niente quindi
grazie io non ho incontrato io ho una
storia sulla gara come si chiamava quel
programma
dall'ultima è affatto tipo in mezzo
spagnolo sembrava forte firth of forth
and four forte forte forte in italiano
ok forse
[Musica]
forte forte forte
io ho scoperto pochi mesi fa che lei non
mi ricordo se è proprio lei o il suo
entourage avevano chiesto di me l'aveva
approvato e poi le hanno detto che
dovevo detto di no ma non arrivò mai
aveva chiesto di dell est nel
collaborare non so se c'era un
presentatore o una specie di vassallo
una specie di forza
sulla re le dissero che io non ero
interessato a quella
[Musica]
che sfiga eolo chiedersi se c'è stata
una critica si che ti ha particolarmente
segnato no no
no mi hanno detto tutti i colori però io
ci godo ok ho un po una roba
masochistica sulle critiche perché vuol
dire che ti ho dato uno schiaffo in
faccia uno che stava dormendo ti dico
una roba che è stata messa in croce da
tutti ma che per me e anche per leandro
è stato un grandissimo banco di prova
che a me ha fatto impazzire è stato
l'eurovision con emma quello dove era
vestita tdm l'ultimo imperatore islam e
roxy lì ci hanno messo incrociano e
tutti i colori soprattutto per la roba
del delle pantaloncini d'oro sotto la
sotto il vestito a volgare brutta
sguaiata too much eccessiva ma
addirittura prossimo
un casino io parlai una sera con tg rai
news 24 come si chiama più le mutande mi
chiama non eravamo lì a copenaghen sulla
storia delle mutande di emma che sarà
creato il delirio dello scandalo fu un
disastro comunque per loro quando invece
secondo me quello è veramente l'esempio
di quanto nel nostro paese ci sia un
double standard quello che fanno gli
uomini fanno le donne c'è una misoginia
di fondo soprattutto nel mondo dello
spettacolo incredibile le donne partono
300 metri indietro quando parte la corsa
del dei singoli delle cose se avessi
fatto la il sanremo 2020 di achille
lauro con una donna l'avrebbero
massacrata avrebbe finito la carriera
immaginatevi una donna che
improvvisamente si spoglia da un
mantello rimane seminuda a cantare una
canzone a sanremo il giorno dopo se
rovigo attendo se poi completamente con
l'atteggiamento del fregarsi
completamente rovinata se sei una che si
fa a rovinare se sei una come madonna ci
crema carriera ma devi essere una come
madonna con un team come quello di
madonna che non esiste le figure
femminili della nostra musica sono
figure rassicuranti vuoi perché non
danno fastidio a nessuno perché sono
giuste sono sempre vestite bene non
fanno mai provocanti troppo brusco
barene troppo suore né troppo simpatica
né troppo serie oppure sono rassicuranti
nel senso che sono delle figlie ma la
via di mezzo non c'è mai non c'è una
[ __ ] che usa il suo essere [ __ ] come
un'arma per che esprime quello che ha
reso grande madonna c'è moda una parlava
di sessualità da strafiga un certo punto
perché era comunque molto bella però ti
stava parlando di una cosa ti stava
parlando di femminismo diritti lgbt
concettualizza ndaw il potere del
desiderio femminile è una cosa potente
ancora oggi oggi ancora spaventa il
desiderio femminile una cosa è un tabù
quindi non c'è una donna nel nostro
mercato che in realtà è libera di dire
tutto quello che vuole o di fare tutto
quello che vuole mentre ci sono degli
uomini liberi di fare quello che
vogliono vittoria rimane skin secondo me
è legittimata a essere così
libera anche come si presenta con i
cerotti esatto perché in un gruppo di
uomini fosse stata l'ho capito se vi
fosse stata solo e non avesse avuto
leader spa avverte ho capito poter ger
damiano fa dei concerti in guepiere
pensa una donna italiana che fa un
concerto in guepiere ho capito cosa non
saresti mainstream perché ci deve essere
che la donna deve essere per essere
presa sul serio deve essere
respinta si è spenta pseudo suora
coperta perché se non sei credibile se
si vede da rocchette e finché le donne
vanno dietro a questo discorso che per
essere prese sul serio devono abbassare
il tono del di come si vestono come si
propongono non andremo da nessuna parte
ti posso chiedere una cosa io perché
adesso hai citato molte volte l'elemento
del disturbo l'elemento del rumore c'è
la possibilità o meglio come si può
esprimere la propria personalità
se si ha una personalità accogliente
cioè senza per forza passare con il
disturbo con la prosecuzione degli al
rientro che a quella roba là perché
essere accoglienti una roba [ __ ] per
esempio lorenzo e accogliente e fatti
suoi concerti c'è il ragazzino la nonna
il bambino è debole lorenzo 1 che
vorresti abbracciare però perché lui di
quella roba lì ne ha fatto bandiera per
esempio a me piace molto lavoro che fai
tu perché quello che mi colpì tantissimo
il tuo ex factor che tratto erano ancora
le edizioni in quelle pazzesche di meg
ascolti e via dicendo che tu giocavi con
una delicatezza
incredibile ma avevi una faccia da
ricordavi tantissimo i protagonisti dei
phoenix van sant quei ragazzini belli
però
pieni di disturbate due lotti si piani
di ombre e quell'ombra liti rendeva ti
rende tuttora magnetico perché
quell'ombra lì poi vuol dire che c'è una
grande luce proprio la farà infatti tu
non sei uno disturbante tu sei uno in
cui non si vorrebbe riparare dopo tanto
sole io verrebbe certi in bocca
facciamo avere un estratto
per te nata fatto un complimento qui ti
ha spiegato perché il mondo
tendenzialmente vorrebbe tosco nato in
gola quando c'è qua si finisce scivola
però scusate se io cerco sempre di si
torna sempre di abbassare o magari si
sacro e profano sempre comunque a questo
punto solo un'ultima domanda male perche
stock cioè è sì o no sì sì totale
che sarei venuto in ciabatte se non mi
avesse giudicato male non mi
siederò birks panato no no io adesso non
si sa perché se c'era lui e quindi ho
rispolverato tutto quello che sono meno
di camerino la ragazza aveva una tipo
fare la doccia con rocco siffredi capito
cioè ad un'ansia che un ansini con lo
sguardo crudele scherzo minibikers taxi
ragazzi avete qualche ultima domanda e
leona mai come mi trovi adesso invece
matera voi cambia vi trovi lucido no è
il tuo designer preferito se si può dire
non voglio crearti un problema politico
designer all time
favorite bottiglie in botti permetta tra
i nuovi mi piace molto christian boaro
che un caro amico che sono contento che
sta avendo grande successo lo conosco da
20 anni e si merita tutto questo
grande grande attenzione su di lui
perché è veramente non sono bellissima
persona bravissimo designer che merita
adesso di avere lo spotlight offeso i
cortissimi per lo amo la domanda perché
vaccinato tra l'altro dal fatto e quello
che vuoi fatti sui tic toc perché per me
tic toc mi rendo conto di essere
veramente vecchio quando la top non
capisco niente è ancora non era dovuto
insegnare from bell'azione di categoria
pazzesco
fatto grease sapeva lazio mi sono fatto
un bacio di cuneo infinito per riuscire
a fare tutti i passi perché non mi
volevano togliere ma tra l'altro hai
fatto tipo cento anni di nigris così io
ho fatto
135 replica
[Musica]
pensi del look della genesi
delle cose che stanno tornando cioè
jeans a vita bassa
beckloff top
[Applauso]
avere una grande verità mi fa ridere
perché all'epoca quella roba lì che
adesso va di matera ci si vestivano
quelli considerati tamarrissimi c'è il
crop toppa farfalla il culo fuori e i
tamarri si che siano così qualifiche si
vestivano prada ok però mi piace perché
una roba [ __ ] perché secondo me poi
quelli che in realtà ci hanno un po
fatto divertire in quegli anni li si
siano così paris hilton nicole richie
lindsey lohan
quindi ti piace che si poi che lo
spazzino come una figata nuova mi fa
ridere perché tra l'altro veramente è
veramente chip c'è nel senso all'epoca
era veramente chip vestirsi così c'è
qualcosa prima di salutarci che vorresti
dire che non è detto che vorresti
ribadire che non è ribadito ma ragazzi
no io vi ringrazio per avermi invitato
permettere al suo bellissimo pensavo
massacrato qui da voi a metterò un po
così però bello grazie finissimo viva la
libertà evviva assolutamente grazie
mille
baci ti svegli al mattino
e sporchi il
faro ati corpo di curko assurda un po
riscontrate corpo a note core core e
core così dice ancora di porco the spoon
e da una green a te do na crina nota
chiamo
affidiamo così a janko cosa che voglio
togliermi un peso sulla coscienza vai
perché quando il citato crismi è
risvegliato un ricordo come tu mi ha
invitato più volte a vedere con lo
spettacolo io ho sempre finto di essere
stato impegnato quando compilato a voi
invitava i più volte è tristano 23 volte
almeno sicuramente qualcuno ha proposto
mio
io non ho quella mente c'è proprio non
ci arriva ma sa benissimo che dicevo non
ce la posso fare posso dirti qualcuno ha
incendiato la riunione posso che di
qualcun altro ha cercato di farci fare a
entrambi cose che non volevamo ottimo
quindi sei sereno ammessa che cosa
importa che poggi 6 qui io non ti volevo
nel pubblico
ottimo morto suicida sulla coscia e così
finiamo bene perché è onesto oggi
sarebbe a vederti
[Musica]
io ho umoristi o una ricerca cosmetica
la finiamo finora ma vediamo da chiamo
certo fatto ragazzi la prima puntata di
feroci finisce qui ormai siamo partiti
non ci si può più fermare cavolo
eh si non aveva parlato di un sacco di
cose ma al di là di tutti gli spunti di
riflessioni del mondo di quello che ci
siamo detti noi speriamo in primis di
essere riusciti a tenervi compagnia
abbia parlato di serenità ma per la
prossima puntata i vestiti abbiamo
deciso di toglierli avremo infatti come
ospite se una persona che ha fatto della
nudità il proprio lavoro da noi feroce
tutto ragazzi e ragazze un graffio
capito perché
becker orazio la carezza non rimane
metteteci il grave una cosa che rimane a
bella gara
[Musica]
[Applauso]